The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's start.
What's energy?
This being a Sloan
class, we do cold calls.
So I walk up to Eric
and I say, how should we
define energy for this class?
AUDIENCE: I would define
energy as currency.
I think it's the
price [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Currency.
So we should be doing
monetary economics, as opposed
to thinking about
electric power and stuff.
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess I
shared my personal view.
As an engineer, I
see energy going
into everything we manufacture.
PROFESSOR: But if
it's just money,
then there's nothing
special about this class.
We could just do plain
old price theory,
or we could just
plain old micro,
or we could do plain monetary.
AUDIENCE: Like I can't print
infinite amounts of energy.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see if everybody agrees.
Julian, where are you on this?
How would you define energy?
AUDIENCE: The
ability to do work.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We're now into basic physics.
Even I remember that.
I am an alumnus.
Perhaps we could be a
little less abstract.
What are some
interesting examples
that fit under that
very broad 801 heading?
AUDIENCE: Oh, under
that very broad heading,
I mean, we use energy for a
very broad variety of uses,
from keeping the lights on,
transportation, manufacturing.
It's really kind of integrated
in everything we make or do,
from an economics or
engineering standpoint.
It supports all of
our communications.
Like without energy, or at
least electrical energy,
and petroleum energy, we would
really kind of be nowhere.
PROFESSOR: But we'll probably
exclude the ability to do work
that you have just personally.
And we'll probably exclude
some forms of energy
that don't do useful work.
But what you're
saying is there's
a wide variety of sources
and a wide variety of uses.
That's true.
But you could probably,
as you just did,
name the principal ones.
Let me ask Sam.
Why are you
interested in energy?
AUDIENCE: One of the
things I'm really
interested in new sources
of energy, renewable sources
and moving away
from fossil fuels.
That's part of the reason
I'm doing [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Step one back.
Why are you interested in that?
AUDIENCE: I think one of the
main problems we have right now
with international relations is
sources of oil and petroleum.
PROFESSOR: So you're
interested in energy security
kinds of questions.
OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Developing nations
that haven't yet [INAUDIBLE]
to their grids.
[INAUDIBLE] newer
sources of energy
versus old traditional
sources that [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So can you think
about some-- can there
be some sort of leapfrogging
strategy the way
developing countries have
bypassed wireline telephones
and jumped to mobile.
Is there something
like that in energy?
Yeah, we're going to do
less on developed countries
than I'd like.
But we will do
some, because that's
a very interesting question.
OK.
A variety of interests.
We had a couple of definitions
of the energy problem.
I'm sorry for the US
focus, but we will broaden.
We had a couple of
definitions of energy problem
in those answers.
One has to do with the
possibility of running out.
Sustainability.
Another has to do
with environment.
Are there any other aspects
to the energy problem?
And energy security,
international dependence.
Are there any other aspects
to the energy problem?
That people have thought about.
I mean, if there is
an energy problem.
You hear about it all the time.
Is there anything else?
Sarah?
AUDIENCE: Cost and
market efficiency.
Because when you
don't have storage,
you have things
like wind power that
can cause a lot of
problems in the market.
PROFESSOR: So there
are two things there.
One is even if we don't run out,
it might get really expensive.
So it's not a question
of, oh my God,
this is the last drop of oil.
It's, oh my God, this
drop of oil is $7,000.
That's a different
kind of problem.
Economists like the second part.
Or think that the
world tends to get you
to the second kind, not the last
drop, but the expensive drop.
And then the issue of
how do you actually
do renewables when
renewables don't
work like dispatchable power?
OK.
Those are energy problems.
Why haven't they been solved?
Yeah.
That was-- either
you're waving for flies,
or you're ready to go.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
problems, like [INAUDIBLE],,
people tend to focus usually
just on the supply side.
But it's actually kind of
both supply and demand.
And the US has one
of the highest demand
for energy in the entire world.
So the country used to
be a major oil exporter,
prior to World War II.
And now really one of
the major oil importers.
So a big problem
is it's actually
the mentality of the consumers
in the US, excessive spending,
so on and so forth.
PROFESSOR: Well, apart
from being terrible people,
which I give you.
I mean, there are
a lot of, you know,
it costs us money to
import all this oil.
It's expensive.
The price varies.
I'll talk about
that a little bit.
Why is this not a problem
that the markets--
why aren't some of
these problems problems
that markets solve?
AUDIENCE: I think that there
are huge barriers to entry,
because the cost of laying
down the infrastructure.
You talk about the power
distribution infrastructure
is immense, and it's
something that I
think only entities such as
the government can afford,
because I don't think that
the private sector would
be capable of funding such
a huge research endeavor.
PROFESSOR: Well,
except almost all
the US power grid is privately
funded and privately owned.
Not all of it.
But most of it.
So we built it before.
But you have a point.
Where I would go with that, and
I'll spend some time on this,
is things move slowly in energy,
because of all the capital.
Doesn't mean they don't
move, but they move slowly.
In one presentation, we use the
analogy of turning a tanker.
You can do it.
It's not easy, and
it takes a while.
Jackie, you had a thought.
AUDIENCE: I think there's a
lack of consensus as to what
should be done, because there's
such a wide variety of opinions
and interests at state,
political, economic, social
that there's no way to-- or
there hasn't been a way so far
to agree on something.
PROFESSOR: So we could maybe--
two alternative ways
which we heard a lot
about in the recent past to
deal with the oil use problem
is drill baby drill,
or conservation.
And you could imagine a world
in which you would do both,
but you're right.
There's no particular consensus.
Does there need to be
a consensus, though?
Think about food.
There's no consensus on food.
We don't have a food problem.
But we eat a lot.
And you know, we're leading
the obesity epidemic.
I'm doing my part.
But we don't have a
national food policy.
I mean, we have a farm policy.
But it's been in
place for a long time.
It doesn't actually
do that much.
So why do we need
an energy policy?
AUDIENCE: I think
at the point where
we are in the energy problem
requires some major steps that
means government won't
necessarily-- government
or large businesses, or
some kind of large entity
will have to be
involved in that.
PROFESSOR: OK, you're worried
about scale questions.
Since you posed the question,
you can answer the question.
AUDIENCE: I think it's not
necessarily of corporations
not having money to
invest in energy projects.
That's not really true.
But the government is
necessary because most
of the very, very major energy
problems, the energy projects
will involve an investment
timeline that will
take 20, 30 years to play back.
So as people who
run a corporation,
I mean, they don't have
personal interest necessarily
[INAUDIBLE],,
because the timeline
that they're going to be in
that corporation is so limited.
So a big part of it is just
the structure of corporations
doesn't really favor
that sort of investment.
So the government needs to step
back and think about long term
interests.
PROFESSOR: But we did
build the existing power
grid and all of the
existing infrastructure
with private money.
So what's new now?
AUDIENCE: Well,
I think back then
also like corporations
tend to be run
much more by large families.
So in that case, people
did have an interest
in how companies were
performing over the long run,
because they're think
about my kids are going
to take over this company.
And I think about how--
I mean, like a big part of how--
PROFESSOR: Well, I give
you that possibility.
But in electric
power, it wasn't true.
Thomas Edison set up
the first company.
It was not a family company.
So electric power
doesn't fit it.
Let me try another line.
See what Andrea says.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to mention also
that one issue with electricity,
for example, is that once it's
in the grid, you have no idea.
You can differentiate
whether it comes
from coal or from nuclear
or whatever source.
So that's an issue in pricing,
which may cause issue--
which may cause people
not to take initiative
from different sources to
solve a common problem, which
could be the grid, or
maybe something else.
And another thing is
that, which is also true,
though, with food, so I got
kind of perplexed with that,
is that it's an
international issue that
may involve many players.
So it's hard to have
different countries agree
upon certain standards.
As we've talked a
lot, we've heard a lot
about developing countries
versus developed and all that.
PROFESSOR: So we're going--
let me pursue that a
little bit, because I
think it takes us down the road
I've been hoping to go down,
which is why do we
all need to agree?
We don't all have
common food standards.
We don't all have agreement
on a lot of things.
Why are many countries involved?
Why might Canada and the US
need to agree on certain things
related to energy?
AUDIENCE: Because,
I mean, some issues
that are coming to
my mind right now
are, firstly, that you
have the allocation
of the sources of energy
are given in the world.
So you may have a region of
abundance in some resource,
and not abundance in some other
resources, so you need to have
[INAUDIBLE].
And the source where you have
them, as opposed to the source
where you use them
might not be the same.
So then, again, you may have
to [INAUDIBLE] in those two
countries.
Plus what you do here may
affect-- so if I pollute here,
it affects what
goes on in Canada.
PROFESSOR: I heard
the magic word.
If we pollute here,
it affects Canada.
If we burn coal in Ohio, it
affects people around the power
plant, elsewhere.
We talked about pollution.
An awful lot of energy
policy is driven
by environmental concerns.
You will recall
from basic economics
the notion of an externality,
that activity A done by--
entity A effect's entity
B outside the market.
Climate change, local
pollution of various kinds
drives a lot of energy policy,
which is one reason why
people talk about renewables.
Climate change is that issue
writ large, very large,
and we'll come back to that.
The other way that
concept works is if you
think about energy security.
So I don't have an SUV.
But if I had an SUV,
I could drive my SUV,
burn all the gas I wanted.
I would contribute
to oil imports.
But guess what--
and that would make
us less secure as a country.
But the effective on me of
that insecurity is trivial.
There's an externality
there, it's argued.
If you think about oil
imports as being undesirable,
when I drive, it
affects imports.
Doesn't affect me.
Affects everybody
else in the room
because they live in a
country that imports more oil.
So the arguments for a lot of
this stuff is externalities.
That we're going to
spend some time on it.
But the reason private-- the
basic reason private business
hasn't solved all of it--
there are other problems too.
But some of the core problems
are because the market doesn't
deal with externalities.
That's sort of a definition.
Market doesn't solve pollution.
Market doesn't solve other
kinds of externalities.
If you listen to the
State of the Union,
I'm sure you found it riveting.
The president called, as
he had in prior speeches,
for a clean energy standard.
And the way he had
done it earlier
was x percent of electricity
has to come from clean sources
by 2020 or 2030.
Probably not a chance that
Congress will pass that.
But the interesting question is
what might you mean by clean?
And that's the only phrase
he used in the speech.
What do you think
he meant by clean?
Think about all the ways you
can generate electricity.
Which sources count as clean?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] definition
he means nuclear as clean.
Not necessarily renewable,
but clean coal cycle,
and I guess more for the
environmental pollution.
Not necessarily the
infrastructure that--
PROFESSOR: No, he
means environmental.
Exactly right.
Not clear he means nuclear.
A lot of people don't
think nuclear is clean.
But renewables are clean.
Any other thoughts?
I don't know what--
I forget whether
he meant renewable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that when you
don't release more CO2 in
the atmosphere, and then
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What would that be?
AUDIENCE: Solar power.
PROFESSOR: Solar power.
Renewables in general.
Yeah, I mean biomass
properly done can do that.
It's a little tricky.
There's a little
start-up problem.
I mean, you cut down all
the trees and burn them.
On its face, it's not
a great thing to do.
But if you're
planting, you can keep
that sustainable after a while.
He actually also meant
some uses of natural gas,
which get half credit.
It's kind of complicated.
So it's going to be raise or
lower the price of electricity
if we did it?
AUDIENCE: Probably raise.
PROFESSOR: Probably raise.
Because if it was
going to lower it,
you probably wouldn't need a
federal push to get it done,
right?
That the market can deal with.
And I'm not quite sure
why I asked that question,
because the obvious
answer is legislation.
So we've fiddled and diddled
with a lot of these questions.
And I want to answer
that question myself,
because the question
is, why is there
a social science class in
the energy studies minor?
What in heaven's name
does social science
have to do with what's clean,
what are the reasons why
we have an energy problem,
what are our concerns,
whether you achieve
that goal or not.
I'm going to give you sort of
how those of us who thought up
this course think
about the energy system
from a social science
point of view.
This may be my
best graphic ever.
So most of what we talk about
when we talk about energy
are flows from things
like coal through, say,
electricity generation,
into the provision
of energy services like toasting
your toast in the morning.
And an awful lot of
technology is in here is there
and how do you get primary
energy from the sun,
from coal, from nuclear power,
whatever, how do you convert it
to something
useful, and then how
do you get services from it.
And that's great stuff.
I'll have something to say
about what's in that box.
But that's not mainly just
to get systems straight,
as opposed to devices.
That's not mainly what
we're going to talk about.
We're going to talk about
what drives the flows.
Well, there's a supply side.
You find energy.
You convert it.
Some of that's
done by government.
Some of it's done by
private enterprises.
There's a demand
for energy services,
mainly not for energy.
Where does that come from?
How are those decisions made?
How are the supply
decisions made?
So if you think about
devices and systems in here,
what are in the higher
boxes are the decisions
about how they're operated,
how intensively they're used.
Supply and demand interact--
too many arrows--
supply and demand
interact through markets.
The markets, as well as the
decisions on both sides,
affect what's in that technology
box and how it's used.
Stepping back, there
are a whole lot
of things that I
think of as stocks.
Things like reserves of
oil, existing buildings,
infrastructure, cars, you could
add technologies, that underlie
the operation of the system.
And that's the
underlay the operation.
They too are shaped by decisions
on the supply and demand side.
How much gasoline you use is
shaped by today's technology.
It's also shaped by past
purchasing decisions of cars.
How much do we use
to heat buildings
is shaped by the latest
fancy technology,
and the buildings that were
built a half a century ago.
And what retrofit
possibilities there are.
But that's fun.
So we're going to
look at decisions
on the supply and demand side.
But those decisions are
affected by regulation.
And the markets are affected
by regulations and laws
of various kinds.
Now, there's a natural tendency
to take those as given.
To say, OK, what I need to know
to operate in this world is,
well, what are the
laws and regulations
that affect what we can
do in the energy sphere?
But if you want
to change things,
and I heard a number of you
wanting to change things,
that's not good
enough, because what
goes on in laws and
regulations affects
what gets done down here,
what's used to do what?
To produce, to convert, to use.
And affects the
kinds of decisions
that households, firms,
other kinds of organizations,
universities make.
So we're going to spend
a little time saying,
where do those come from?
What's the political
process look like?
Those political processes
are shaped, obviously,
by firms and households
and other organizations.
I will also say, we will--
so there's a little
political science there.
There will also be a little bit
of organizational behavior here
and a little bit of
psychology there,
when we look at how these
decisions actually get made.
So behind everything are
a set of norms and values
and traditions that really
shape the political context.
You listen to any campaign
speech, you hear a lot of that.
You don't necessarily
hear a lot of-- you
hear a lot of that, and
then some specific policy.
But you hear a lot of that.
And that's important.
And campaign speeches
in different countries
say different things when they
sound themes about traditions
and values and norms.
But the political process
operates within them.
We'll talk about that.
So we want to talk about not
only sort of how systems work
and how supply and demand
interact in the energy space,
but in fact, how that
whole structure is shaped
by, if you will, a higher
order more fundamental--
the higher order in
the chart processes
in the political sphere,
in the social sphere.
So the reason why we're
doing social science
is the system involves people.
And social science, economics,
political science, sociology,
anthropology, social
psychology, things
I've read about at
least, these are
all ways of looking at
systems that involve people.
And if you want to change a
system that involves people,
you need to think about
the kinds of things
we're going to talk about here.
So we're going to try to give
you some basic understanding,
or at least some sensitivity
to the tools that come out
of the social
sciences that can help
you understand,
and with some luck,
can help you drive change.
This is not a
prediction or a course
where we talk about the
future will look like x.
That's for you guys to decide.
This is a course where we try
to help you shape the future.
The annual energy review comes
out of the Energy Information
Agency.
It says AER 2010.
It's published in 2011,
the latest data, or 2010.
This is energy consumption per
person in the United States
over time.
You will notice that it sort
of peaks in the '70s someplace,
and is flat.
Now, if you think about
how the cars we drive,
compare it-- well,
you may not know this,
but how the cars we drive
compared to the cars folks
drove in the '70s,
they are bigger,
and have a lot more horsepower.
And what our homes
look like compared
to homes built in the
'70s is they are bigger,
and they tend to be
centrally air conditioned.
If you think about computer
use and appliance use,
there's a lot more of it.
But energy consumption
per capita is flat.
I'll show you energy
per dollar of GDP,
but you might expect
it to be declining.
And what that tells you is first
of all, there is efficiency.
And second of all, if
you think for a minute,
maybe we're doing different
things than we did in the '70s.
Like less manufacturing.
Another graph, I
love this graph.
Impossible to read, I
expect, from the back.
But this is energy consumption
per person across the States.
And there, on the virtuous
right end is Massachusetts.
How about that,
we are good folks.
Is there anybody
here from Wyoming?
Anybody?
Nobody from Wyoming?
No one will admit to
being from Wyoming?
All right.
I'm betting against Alaska.
How about Louisiana?
North Dakota.
Working from the left in.
IA is Iowa, yes?
Iowa.
Anybody from-- surely
somebody is from Iowa.
OK, we have no
Midwesterners here.
How about Texas, South
Dakota, or Kentucky?
Ah, we have the
Texas delegation?
OK.
Gentlemen, how come we
use so much less energy
than you do per capita?
Pickett.
Wyatt?
Take a run.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: We do a lot
of farming in Kentucky.
So that may have
something to do with it.
PROFESSOR: Farming is
actually a fairly energy
intensive activity these days.
You're driving a
lot of machinery.
It uses a lot of energy.
So that's one thing.
OK.
Anything else?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Unlike Massachusetts,
where a lot of people
walk, especially in
Boston, in South Dakota
everything's really
spread apart,
so everybody drives there.
PROFESSOR: So it's
lower density.
There's probably a lot
more driving per capita.
Yeah.
Matt, you raised--
you identified
as one of this crowd.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in Texas.
PROFESSOR: It's what?
AUDIENCE: Air conditioning?
PROFESSOR: Air conditioning.
Hotter summers.
Probably a lot more central air.
AUDIENCE: Probably
a drive everywhere.
PROFESSOR: A lot more
spread out, yeah.
It's interesting,
when you first think
about energy use in
Massachusetts, you might think,
gee, we have cold winters.
We must heat these buildings.
You notice, there's
Hawaii right next to us,
where they don't heat
anything ever really.
So there are lots
of differences.
And you pointed to some of them.
They're transportation related.
There's also not a lot of
manufacturing in Massachusetts
anymore.
So we don't have a
big industrial load.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wait, so California,
is California right next
to Massachusetts there?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, California.
AUDIENCE: Because California
also there's a lot of farming,
and we drive a lot.
PROFESSOR: All true.
But very little
manufacturing anymore.
But you're right.
There are a lot of puzzles here.
I mean, there is Arizona.
And you want to talk about
central air conditioning,
you have to have central
air conditioning in Arizona.
So whereas northern
California, you still need it,
but it's not desperate.
Yeah?
Jessica?
AUDIENCE: How does this do
manufacturing, for example?
Does it ration it to the
state that [INAUDIBLE] done
and those residents, or to
where the products are made?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Where the plant is.
AUDIENCE: What about
some of these--
or the big states
that make electricity,
have big coal plants, big
oil plants, big everything?
Is that proportioned
for that state, or--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
will be in the state.
It'll be in the state.
I mean, California is a pretty
light user of electricity.
We're a pretty light
user of electricity.
Hawaii is light.
In part, because
those are states
where it's really expensive.
It's expensive here for
a variety of reasons.
California, heavily
environmental.
Hawaii-- it's Hawaii.
I mean, it's all oil-fired,
and the oil comes by tanker.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was going to say
that I assume the differences
also come from state laws and
regulations and how those few
decision-makers--
I don't know.
I mean, for example, you
just mentioned [INAUDIBLE]..
I assume it might
be just because you
have different
taxes, so it might
be more expensive in
certain states, or oil
might be cheaper
or more expensive,
gasoline, stuff like that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Some of that.
I mean, we'll talk about some
of the state regulations.
Some of the states, like
California, for instance--
and Texas, for that matter--
have strong programs
favoring renewables,
which will add a bit.
But you could imagine, down
the road, it adding a lot.
The environmental standards
are pretty uniform,
but most of the
electricity generated here
is generated by gas.
And we're at the far
end of the pipeline.
So it's not Texas or Louisiana,
where the gas is there.
It comes by comes by pipeline.
In fact, we import some, LNG.
Liquefied gas.
AUDIENCE: It was
also, per capita,
places that have a
relatively small population
for their activity--
like Alaska,
where there's a lot
of mining and stuff,
and there's not
that many people.
Doesn't that skew
it a little bit?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
But if you put two Alaskas
next to each other,
you would have more people,
but still the same per capita.
So I don't know if there are
scale effects, particularly.
I think density works.
Alaska's doing a lot of
energy-intensive stuff.
A lot of travel within Alaska.
A lot of heating in Alaska.
I don't think it's
the absolute scale.
I mean, consider Hawaii,
which is also quite small.
But Hawaii doesn't--
they're not mining anything.
There's nothing to mine.
They're not doing a
lot of manufacturing.
They can't drive that much.
OK.
Brendan?
AUDIENCE: It looks to
me like it's mainly
red states versus blue states.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Well, hold that for a moment.
We want to get deeper
into the semester
before we're really political.
But-- so this is energy
per dollar of GDP.
And it's been declining
for a long time,
reflecting efficiency,
reflecting the decline
of manufacturing, reflecting--
well, those are two big ones.
But probably other
factors, as well.
Efficiency in energy
use, efficiency
in electricity generation,
and other dimensions.
I find this one interesting.
That's BTUs per dollar.
So that's real on real.
This is dollars on dollars.
This is energy spending.
And you'll see,
that's not so stable.
And that's one reason--
that's one component
of what people
think of as the energy problem.
I mean, all of a sudden, we're
cruising along fat and happy,
and boom!
We move from something
like 8% of GDP
to something like 14% of
GDP to pay the energy bill
over a few years.
And then this is--
come on, where are we?
This is the recent oil
spike and oil collapse.
This is a law-- we'll talk
about this next Wednesday.
And this is a period when we got
very complacent about energy,
and you didn't hear much
about energy from anybody.
So prices move.
And that is a source of concern.
Let me talk about sources
of energy consumption.
If you extend this graph back--
way back-- it starts with wood.
If you go back far enough, New
England didn't have forests.
They were cut down for energy.
And gradually, it
dawned on people
that perhaps that's
not a good way forward.
They have these
wonderful photographs--
I'll grab one if I can--
of Vermont.
Basically, hills of mud.
Hills of mud.
Because the wood was there.
They cut the wood down.
That gave them scrub.
They used the scrub
to graze sheep.
There was a big boom in wool.
You graze sheep.
They eat everything.
You get raw dirt.
It runs down when it rains.
We move from wood to coal.
So you would have a wood peak
over here, and coal going up.
But this is since 1950.
This renewable energy,
which is pretty high in 1950
and grows slowly,
is mostly hydro--
mostly big dams built
in the '30s and '40s.
You'll see not too
many built since.
The recent run-up
is other things.
You see nuclear power
go up and go flat.
Coal continues to rise.
Natural gas.
You might think that
this downturn has
something to do with policy,
and you would be right.
This has something
to do with prices.
But you see natural gas kind
of flat with a little uptick
here at the end.
We're going to spend
a lot of time talking
about that uptick at the end.
And oil continues to grow.
If you look at
imported energy, we're
basically pretty
self-sufficient except for oil.
A whole lot of this is natural
gas from Canada, which is--
that's, like, 80% of our
natural gas imports, which
doesn't keep too many people up
nights, unless you're a hockey
fan.
But oil, over time, continued
to grow until recently.
And we'll talk about that.
Let me unpack that a little bit.
So since at least
the 1970s, there
has been this desire to have
energy independence, which
really means oil independence,
since we're a coal exporter.
Most of our natural gas
imports are from Canada.
And electricity, nothing
happens much across the border.
The main story,
historically, has been,
OK, we're going
to be independent.
OK, this is going to be great.
And there goes consumption.
And in the meantime, production,
depending how you measure it,
peaked some long time ago--
not for want of drilling.
The other interesting
fact, again, you'll
notice that little
uptick at the end.
That little uptick
at the end is shale.
And if you've been
following the paper,
shale is the big
story in fossil fuels.
It's also a big
environmental story.
And we will spend
some time on it.
But that little uptick--
and there's a similar uptick
in natural gas--
is a big deal, the
start of something.
This graph won't look
like this in five years.
How's that for complexity?
This is energy flows.
And you can spend all
day long looking at this,
and it would be good for you.
But let me just point
out a few highlights.
Over here, really, is
sort of primary energy.
How many BTUs, with
100% efficiency,
would there be in the petroleum
we use, the coal we use,
the gas we use, and so on?
You see, first of all, that
petroleum and coal and gas
are still the main story.
If you go to the right,
you will also see,
this is how much energy
does useful work.
This is the energy that gets
lost mainly in waste heat.
So anybody looking
at that diagram
would say, gee, there's
an enormous opportunity
for efficiency.
Now, you could also
see, in electricity,
there's a lot of it wasted.
That's mostly at the
generating station.
And a lot of money and effort
has gone into reducing that,
but it is not trivial.
The other thing to note is due
to breakdown by residential,
commercial, industrial,
and transportation.
It's not quite a third
for residential plus
commercial, industrial,
and transportation,
but it's kind of close--
ballpark, a third
in each bucket.
Transportation is
obviously almost all oil,
and most of the oil
goes to transportation.
You see the beginnings--
I mean, solar is trivial.
Wind is a lot bigger.
It's grown rapidly.
Little bit of-- and
hydro is pretty steady.
Again, you can stare at these.
It's interesting to look
at this graph over time.
And I'll show you an old one.
But that's sort of the basic
flow outline of the system.
That's that red box and
what it looks like unpacked.
There we go.
I just find this interesting.
I did it a few years ago.
This is, who uses industrial?
On that industrial
box, where does it go?
What industries use energy?
And it turns out that a quarter
of it goes to bulk chemicals--
just heat to drive reactions.
Paper gets 10%, oil
refining gets 15%,
and the rest is pretty spread.
If you look at energy--
BTUs per dollar of value
added, turns out cement
is very energy-intensive.
As those of you who
know cement will
recognize, that it's a major
source of CO2 emissions--
both the energy and the reaction
that that energy produces.
Now, if you look forward--
and we're going to do a fair
amount looking forward--
this is sort of a
general consensus.
And it underlies, I think,
the reasons why a lot of you
are here.
You sense this is a place
where change needs to happen,
of one kind or another.
Again, I didn't make
it a required reading,
but you can look at the
National Research Council report
that this is from to
see why they think this.
But it's not easy.
Here's what that graph
looked like in 1982.
You know, it doesn't
look that different.
Main difference is, you
could stare at these-- again,
this will be on Stellar.
It's not as complete.
The main difference
you can see is
that we used to use
a fair amount of oil
to generate electricity.
We don't do that anymore.
We really don't use
oil for electricity,
for a range of reasons.
It's too expensive,
among other things.
And that's-- still,
transportation is mostly oil.
We still use a lot of coal--
oil, coal, natural gas.
The other stuff is
still pretty-- was
pretty small, is pretty small.
There's still,
again, this rejected
energy, useful energy--
waste energy, useful energy.
So if you look at this,
you say, my heavens.
Again, you could
look at the flows.
And this is that they weren't
quite as good at doing
this graph at Livermores.
They came to be, in later years.
You look at it and you say,
the system doesn't move fast.
How can it move?
Well, it could move
if we all decided--
in a lot of utilities, you can
opt to buy green electricity.
That is to say, if
20% of the people--
20% of the usage is
green, then the utility
is obliged to get 20% of its
energy from green sources.
We could all say, and your
parents could all say,
we want green electricity.
Well, if everybody did that,
it would be a big change.
Not quite clear what
the companies would do
or how they would cope with it.
It would be a big change.
Is it likely?
No.
It's expensive.
And what I do isn't going
to affect the system much.
If we all do it
together, it might.
But that's another story.
Suppose we develop
great new technologies,
which I hope many of you do.
Well, where does
the money come from?
Energy, as a number of
people said at the outset,
is a big-dollar business.
You don't do it at the PC.
Three people in a garage don't
do the Facebook of energy.
I mean, there's scope
for IT of energy,
but if you really want to
change how the work gets done,
you're talking serious R&D.
You're talking serious scaling.
Should the government
decide where to invest?
If so, how?
Can you rely on
large energy firms?
Some of them are really big.
Southern Company is
building a nuclear reactor--
first in a long time.
That's a lot of money.
Intel spends billions
on fabs, so maybe Intel
should spend the billions.
Are they going to do it?
Is Southern Company going
to do something radical?
Small companies?
We're going to talk about this.
Because the question of,
what kinds of organizations
are best suited to do
what in the innovation
process is kind
of important here.
I mean, if you
think you're going
to revolutionize electricity
generation with $100,000
and three people, no.
No.
You might produce
something basic
that somebody would
buy that would
be sold to somebody
bigger that might,
but figuring out how that
process works is important.
Another way to transform
the energy system
is to really tighten
environmental regulation.
And if you've been
reading the paper,
you've been reading about
regulations of coal-fired power
plants--
that some of them will
have to shut down.
Well, if you really tighten
environmental regulation,
you would-- could--
transform the system.
Are there votes for it?
Is it going to be done at the
state level, the federal level?
Does it matter where it's done?
Where are the votes for it?
How would you get
the votes for it?
What does the
opposition look like?
And what about this
regulatory process?
Has EPA gone wild?
Have the courts gone wild?
How does that work?
There are no laws passed.
You have a blocking Republican
coalition in Congress.
And yet EPA is coming out
with these very strong
environmental rules.
Where does that come
from-- very strong,
as perceived by industry.
Where does it come from?
How is it driven?
Where might it go?
You could imagine the
extension of state programs.
29 states and the
District of Columbia
now require certain
fractions of energy--
electricity-- to be generated
from renewable sources.
You could tighten those.
California has tightened
it pretty tight.
Texas has been very effective.
Texas has a lot of wind energy--
an absurd amount of wind energy.
You could imagine-- we got
EPA from a social movement.
We got the Civil Rights
laws from a social movement.
You could imagine a social
movement that would basically
call for transformation.
Of course, people would
have to agree on what
the transformation should be.
It would need something
coherent, something simple,
something like Martin
Luther King's speeches,
something like
Silent Spring that
banned DDT because people got
upset that birds were dying.
It would require some
rallying cry like that.
Is it possible?
And finally, how are we
going to do energy security,
and what does it mean?
Suppose we're completely
self-sufficient for oil.
Does that mean we're immune
to international price shocks?
Does that mean closing
the Straits of Hormuz
would have no effect on us?
What if the lights
went out in Europe?
What would that do?
What if world prices went up?
Would we subsidize oil to
keep domestic prices down?
So when you think about,
how might transformation
happen-- oh, and electric
cars powered by coal.
I have to say, I love to ask
my environmentalist friends
in the Midwest who have
electric cars whether they're
enjoying their coal-powered
car or not, because it is.
So it takes a little
bit of a systems view.
Two observations, and
then I'll let us go.
And the observations are
that, in this business,
history matters.
And I have to give
you this graph,
because it's a fantastic--
has anybody read
Tufte, the Visual Display
of Quantitative Information?
Beautiful book.
At some time in
your life, read it.
It's a book on, how can
you use visual displays
to get across information?
This shows when capacity was--
when US-generating capacity was
built and how it's powered.
So you get a whole lot of
information out of this.
You get out of this that
there's a lot of capacity
still running built before
1960, a ton of capacity
built before 1980, and
a lot of coal capacity
built before 1980.
The recent capacity over
here is almost all gas,
although you see a little
coal coming online here.
But it's almost all gas--
and very recently, wind.
But there's a lot of money
invested in these plants.
And for at least some
of them, coal is cheap.
The plant's built.
The running cost--
the cost of buying the coal,
putting it in, and generating
electricity from
it-- is really low.
So the cost of shutting them
down and replacing them--
doesn't matter what
they cost to build.
It's a cost of-- the cost
is premature replacement.
Could be very high.
And that's what we're hearing.
On the other hand, many of
these are really dirty--
and compared to the new
stuff, really inefficient.
Turning that ship is not easy.
Yeah, all of the
new stuff is gas.
That's just swell.
That is going to continue.
And this is in response
to a bunch of subsidies
and regulations-- the wind.
But these guys are still here.
They're still here.
Oh, and the nuclear plants--
it's an interesting question.
How long will the
nuclear plants stay?
They've gotten more
efficient over time.
They could run for a while.
Will we build new ones?
Final example of
how history matters.
This is US oil reserves.
We explored for oil
in the lower 48.
We explored for oil in Alaska.
We're exploring for oil-- have
explored for oil-- off-shore.
That's US oil
reserves over time.
So it's not that
we've pumped out--
it's not the difference
between 30 billion barrels
and, I don't know,
22 billion barrels
is the amount we've produced.
No, we've produced a lot more.
But after a while, if
you produce a lot today,
it becomes harder
to find tomorrow.
Who knows how much there is.
But what there is,
is hard to find.
We're deep underwater
off Los Angeles--
not off Los Angeles, off
New Orleans-- off Louisiana.
That's not cheap to go
down a mile and drill.
That's just not cheap.
It was cheaper in Alaska, here.
But we've pumped a lot
of oil out of Alaska.
So that history, that
decision that we're
going to use domestic oil today,
has implications for tomorrow.
OK, I'm going to stop there.
Oh, and I should
just make the point,
over the period of this graph,
world oil reserves-- that
actually includes
us, but we're small.
World oil reserves
more than doubled.
Because people look
for oil in new places.
People had been looking
for oil in the US,
and it gets harder to find.
OK.
Questions or comments?